[Musique]
alors comment ils étaient bail en avait
plusieurs
vous avez là il y en avait environ
l'aller on avait des rièzes et là aussi
l'occident et on avait bloqué mon client
avait la taille et l'âge des fruits est
difficile mais aussi sans chiffres ball
maintenant nous sommes en direct avec
michel michel est-ce que vous pouvez
nous rappeler les scores non merci
michel on continue tout de suite avec
une course de formule en mon sens chez
molly à combien là monsieur bolduc est
recevable
ouais c'est limité à pépère son chien
rentrée vous êtes en retard les petites
aiguilles en bas est grande sur la
droite et ben voila je la mets un petit
peu dans un peu plus de bon sens chez
moi bien entrevoir qu tu peux me donner
le moyen de t'appeler oui bien sûr ces
touches du bas touché ming à droite
gauche exactement grande diagonale à
droite
je vous rappelle que pour ses tirages et
bien la somme à gagner et de amputant sa
mère sur riesch démission du stic
toi vous prenez vos livres à la page pas
tout à fait à la fin mais presque on va
parler de la guerre il ya pas très
longtemps dans mon grand père était
jeune avec les étoiles jaunes et bah
vous êtes bien bourré excusez moi ouais
vous l'auriez entaille grobool il ne
reste que des petits derche désolé
demain matin il fera on se pèle les
couilles dans la région du havre
ça va pas j'ai fait un cauchemar
ah bon mais c'était horrible on vivait
dans un monde sans chiffres mais il y
avait le m bah oui tout
oui toutes les 26 compte est bon
merci à vous d'avoir regardé cette vidéo
on est déjà beaucoup moins d'abonnés que
norman et ça ça fait vraiment plaisir
et sinon tous les vendredis sur le site
et les vidéos du lab alors de la petite
aiguille en bas et la grande en eau